ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément loin de paris
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus se taire ils
ont des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je me rends à castets dans
le département des landes
[Musique]
bonjour luis bonjour on est devant cette
scierie qui est une grande partie de
votre vie oh là on est devant le site de
casse-tête dans lequel je travaille
depuis maintenant trente huit ans ce
site a déjà fermé depuis le coville en
mars
on avait prévu de fermer en juin et puis
le coc vide et en étant là on a été
obligé de se confiner donc du coup on
n'a pas relancé est resté en place
l'unité de rabotage et ça jusqu'au 28
février
j'ai toujours trouvé ce boulot très
intéressant mais voilà j'ai eu la chance
d'évoluer de trouver aussi déjà en phase
qui qui me convenait et certainement à
qui j'avais convenir je pense
voilà je c'était une entreprise aussi
une famille parce que bon honnêtement
c'est aussi voici ce que je ressentais
voilà et globale globalement c'était
plutôt voilà trente huit années
sympa avec effectivement des passages
difficiles mais bon globalement comme
partout je pense et voilà et donc là ça
s'arrête
autrefois tous les plafonds des maisons
étaient en bois donc aujourd'hui c'est
plus vrai
les avant-toits hésiter tout ça on voit
aujourd'hui c'est plus vrai comme ça
c'est un petit marché de niche
malheureusement ça génère pas assez de
mètres carrés pour faire tourner à pour
faire tourner des unités industrielles
comme nous aujourd'hui je me dis que
voilà et c'est peut-être la chance de ma
vie que j'ai pas le choix je veux dire
que la relève dans l'idée c'est ok ou
vous partez vous pleurez bon après on
est on est triste c'est certain mais
voilà c'est malheureusement c'est comme
ça ou alors on essaie de revenir moi je
me dis que la chance de ma vie
voilà j'ai 55 balais sur un tournage je
me remet en question je trouve que c'est
super l'idée c'est de repartir donc en
tant que menuisier moi de travailler
pour le pour la construction pour
adecco dans la conscience là dans la
fabrication de meubles aussi de cuisine
le petit abri jardet revoilà dans
différentes parties voilà je vais
essayer de parler pour l'avenir je
dirais que 55 balais je crois que je le
gros il est fait quoi donc pour moi en
fait c'est maintenant c'est profiter de
la vie et essayer de faire quelque chose
qui me convient qui me plaît parce que
du coup ce sera tout bonus qu'on voit la
bombe du coup luis on va aller chez vous
ça va on y va
dans ce paradis c'est ça il faut pas il
faut pas le dire et parce que moi là et
on veut pas que tout le monde s'y
pointer donc oui cela on arrive dans
votre paradis comme vous dites c'est ça
c'est ça qu'on est chez vous la ou au
coeur de au coeur de la forêt quoi voilà
tout à fait on est ici depuis depuis 11
ans voilà j'ai travaillé pendant dix ans
aussi un artisanat donc j'ai fait
beaucoup de choses chez les gens et à un
moment je me disais qu'un jour ce sera
pour moi que je serai effectivement
quand j'ai fait ma maison j'étais assez
content de pouvoir de pouvoir le faire
pour moi soit l'implantation les
fondations la dalle
toute la charpente à l'intérieur de la
maison j'ai fait tous les meubles qui a
des dents c'est moi qui fais vous avez
un atelier ouais j'ai un petit garage
entre ce à quoi je vais aller vous
chercher les clés on va regarder aller
voilà ici forcément tout est en bois
en tant que ça travailler pas et en ce
moment on va y trouver des citrouilles
et des pastèques les citrouilles pour la
soupe il va c'est que pour la confiture
ah ouais voilà donc on retrouve un peu
l'univers de l'atelier avec qui alain
tente en fait il atteint que j'arrivais
en tous les cas c'est ici j'espère que
ça ça se déroulera dans le futur
aujourd'hui tu as tu te sens oublié par
les pouvoirs publics
moi je fais personnellement ce que je me
pose pas cette question est-ce que je
suis oublions pas - tous les cas je me
suis toujours battue et je continue à me
battre j'avais besoin d'aller de l'avant
donc moi je ne suis pas posé de question
j'ai essayé de faire ce qu'il fallait de
mon côté pour avancer pour pouvoir me
retrouver pour pouvoir vivre
correctement
on a dévalorisé depuis très très
longtemps tous les boulots manuel voilà
lé les gens quand je suis sorti de
l'école menuisier c'est au smic est le
minimum le minimum social et puis bon
les gens qui sont restés pendant des
années il avait le minimum pour ma part
j'avais un collègue c'est quelqu'un qui
maîtrise et qu'ils étaient capables de
te faire un escalier tournant qui allait
sur son chantier prenez les côtes il
faisait une cuisine et tout ça quand ils
demandaient tout cela et tout ça quand
ils descendent salaires le smic le
minimum le smic pendant très longtemps
il ya eu un mépris très certainement
pour les boulons manuel si l'on n'en
serait pas arrivé là moi je dis juste
qu'aujourd'hui si si on était un peu
plus dans le partage
il n'y a pas de raison ça je ne démord
pas il n'y a pas de raison
qu'aujourd'hui est quelqu'un qui a
travaillé par exemple pour 1200 euros tu
vas en 1200 1300 le smic je suis la
commune emile 2003 coco tu peux
concevoir ça et que ce mec pour les
jours il va travailler et en fin de mois
il a des difficultés alors qu'il fait
aucun excès il a des difficultés pour
clôturer mon papa on peut pas accepter
ça un moment je comprends que sont
difficiles mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
quand même que le gars qui va travailler
on revalorise son travail mais je pense
qu'effectivement est-ce qu'il est
logique que quelqu'un gagne 1300 euros
par mois et qu'à côté on est un pdg qui
en gagne 1 qui en gagnent 60 ou 70
milles et en plus il a plusieurs mandats
plusieurs casquettes non monsieur
mais qui sait ils sont pas du même trop
que nous peut-être je ne sais pas voilà
jeu il ya des choses ça sature c'est des
trucs qui me je le comprends pas et on
peut plus accepter pour certains qui
sont dehors qui ont pas d'un qui n'ont
pas d'abri
d'un côté les autres il est il est des
revenus des bagnoles des bateaux
j'arrivais des fois à comprendre qu'ils
aient eu des révolutionnaires à quoi bon
voilà quoi s est malheureusement si tu
avais un message au président la
république aujourd'hui tu veu diret quoi
je serai bien mais teyssieu parce que je
n'aurais pas que quand on prêche
l'exemplarité il faut que sont m on soit
exemplaire sous nos politiques ils ont
des casseroles c'est infernal
alors j'en fais pas de politique mais je
le voyais arrêté en tant que force est
de constater qu'à la télé au fait que
parler de ça des mecs qui ont fait l'été
l'état d'étude et finalement qui ils ont
oublié de faire leur déclaration les
autres ils ont un pays aussi avec cela
il n'aurait pas dû mais mais on part on
parle pas de
de francisco à chaque fois c'est décidé
sonne c'est une foule petit à petit les
années passent et tu fais chez les bills
en quoi tu te dis mais il ya des
tas de choses qui te quitte débecte qui
tu te dis si anormal
ça continue comme ça on en parle au fait
qu'en parler mais bon j'ai quand même
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui c'est le pen
je suis pas l'impression je crois c'est
la certitude que c'est le pognon qui
nous manager à tous et qui commande donc
les lobbies qui ont le pognon ils font
ce qu'il faut pour qu'en fait ça se
déroule comme ils l'ont prévu c'est
toujours plus d'argent pour eux au
détriment malheureusement de la masse
salariale on écrème on écrème on écrème
la masse salariale au profit de plus
gros salaires de reverser des dividendes
aujourd'hui je dirais que notre économie
elle peut plus elle peut plus
fonctionner sans s'inquiéter des gens
qui sont des petites gens quelque part
est de tout de tout ce petit monde de la
masse salariale
aujourd'hui on oublie vraiment beaucoup
de gens me traditionnellement on finit
la séquence par une photo donc c'est ta
nouvelle vie que capitaine nathalie donc
tu vas te mettre derrière cette
magnifique machine mais tu fais comme si
tu piloter cette énorme machine
oui je suis un peu pilotage
[Musique]